what else you got nick gross
hey fellas it's your boy and brown from
southeast idaho
i just uh won another battle against
fedex in this never-ending delivery war
thank god the weather's cooling down
because we know they can't handle the
heat
that's hilarious yeah shout out to that
guy it's tough who do you roll with on
that if you go
fedex or you go ups well there ain't
nothing better when ups pulls up and
you've been waiting for a package
yeah the dude jumps out and around
now i will say this the fedex guy ups
the ups
guys are more old school they're more
like jack the calf muscles on the ups
guy in the brown shorts yeah and they
got the combat boots on
even the japan you can even hear the
muscle working through the pants yeah
it's because they're carrying them big
loads
just say boxes man they say the carrying
boxes stuff the kind of stuff
they are stronger men because they have
good
long-term benefits dental you'll see the
man got clean teethy smiles that you
show your clean ones you know
they've got good stuff at ups he's doing
he gets off of work they gotta wait some
of them to have weight
weight gym at the same ups center you
could do the weights right there if you
want
amazon always seems stressed out because
i think they deliver so many [ __ ]
packages they kind of just throw things
and jump back in amazon
and amazon knows they're about they're
you know seconds away from losing their
job to a drone
you know my mom delivers for amazon
she's always cursing
asking me about drones do i know
anything about new drones
[Laughter]
and i'm like mom yeah ups some real real
ass dudes man
yeah they'll drop off your package one
do a podcast with you oh ups is for real
dude
real jesus and that dolly they get the
dolly out yeah so what is fed fedex is a
little bit more like nouveau
kind of has kind of a french vibe got a
sign
a little fancier i think was it fedex or
uh ups
on castaway someone passed
fedex that's right now i like dhl man
and i invested in their stock years ago
and lost a lot of money but
i thought dhl was going to be that big
hitter when they tried to go internet
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] now what's
happening in the in the latino community
or the
chinese community is uh big if you go if
you uh order [ __ ] from china
i know a lot of usps uh workers are
filipino mm-hmm
you know that again and that is
beautiful so if you have karaoke
yeah then drop off a package it's a
bruno mars
that's a good time why they [ __ ] with
karaoke so now who does the black
community trust the most when it comes
to these delivery companies
usps oh golden brown huh
i don't know what can brown do for you
dog
oh well who do you ship with who i
always go to fedex because it's right by
my house oh okay so proximity
yeah that's why i go off i don't know
where i don't know where the hell i like
ups because they get them cardboard
boxes in there too
yeah me too you go in there you know
they're trying to compete with the man
amazon trying to take the world over you
you ups still doing the damn thing this
is the u.s market
yeah holy [ __ ] ups dominates
oh wow
ups over 50 the fedex cracking hard
right about 30
if you want to uh ship anything under 13
ounces or under usps is the cheapest
it'll it'll take you a week like you
said that for drugs that dhl be sending
them
drugs what is dhl they're yellow and red
and they delivered beautifully oh yes
yes yep
beautiful units beautiful man suspect
though
dhl baby they're yeah you always see
their
yep they're planes when i always thought
we should have fedex the airline like
why can't
why can a package be guaranteed to be
there tomorrow but i can't you know
because sometimes you get your flight
gets canceled whatever but your box
still gets there you're like how what is
it going on
if fedex did air human i think that's
called jet blue
i'd fly fedex though i think it's called
spirit airlines
no dude the spirit i saw two dogs fight
on the spirit one
two two people had dogs get what you pay
for yeah
it's the king of nice